Các bạn đang lượng có tỷ đang xem xe để sân dại phóng lượng giống dự chữ quy mối lớn,
nhà mồn định thị trường năng lượng quan cầu, cho bất cảnh xúc độ cải trường đông làm xa
tăng dự giống dọn đoạn hình công.
Theo tông tin được đưa ra tại cuộc họp khẩn của các quan chức năng lượng ngày 1.8 tại Paris,
kế hoặc này có thể vượt mất kỷ lục một chăm táng miệng ai trụ thủ dầu,
tương được bâm ra thì chương trong cơ đường dại phóng khò dự chữ năm 2020,
không trai miệng ai.
Tuy nhiên, quy định quay cùng, tăng có sự đông thận của tất cả các cuo gia thành viên,
để giám đoều ai nghe, Fatiburo, Chuyiết, khi chương dụng mỏ đứng mặt với nhiều dù dù sau nghe mèm chào.
Bây khi một công lệ giám thỏng, và hỏi đợi vận chuyển quay ở biển học mốt gặp nhiều khó khăn,
trong cuộc họp của ngày các bộ trường thủ nhóm, các nếu công nghiệm phát triển an lộn thị dưới cơ bài,
cũng thảo luận khả năng sự dụng khào dự chữ chữ lượng để bù đắt một công thêu hồn.
Nhìn các nước thành viên dè, năm 2019, tỉ thủng giấu dự chữ khẩn cơ của gia,
cũng khoảng sáo trong trường dự chữ thủng mại, đứt lập nhằm bảo đảm anh năng lượng,
chữ cơ của sắp mồn cùng phản cầu.